hey e.t it's the ladies of the collab
[ __ ] and today we're going to be
reacting to some of our best tea talks
we're about to take a look at your first
tick tock we'll start with you
[Music]
camaraderie
watching the video what what thoughts
are going through your head right now i
look super
young at that time i was like 11 like i
think i was like 12
i was very young i look very young who
came up with the idea to pull you out of
frame like that
me i've seen the challenge going around
and i was like you know what
might as well just hop on it yeah so
you've been doing this thing since you
were 11 girl
yeah well eventually i started out
modeling but i got
into like other things just started
doing skins yeah is it ever hard for you
you all to watch back your content
cause the way myra was over here
squirming
they'll be cringy well let's look at
yours kailyn
what are you doing act normal it isn't
normal it's a video
boomerang i'll boomerang myself
this man that's my room
byron was her boyfriend uh yeah he was
oh okay so what went down yeah like we
used to do
i used to sing and he would rap in
videos
he wasn't good at it but i was good and
they kind of
we used to just go viral all the time
and
i love that do you guys still talking
now yeah we're still we're still like
best friends
all right kisha let's move on to yours
are you ready sure
where who
you been where where who
[Music]
and i seen the audio i kept seeing
people just doing the regular stuff and
i'm like nah i like to be different so
i'm like let me act this out because
when i heard it i imagined like my
mother
you know beating me when i come in the
house playing so i was like happened to
you before
huh this from experience yes from
experience
and i actually had my cousin on the
couch watching me he didn't know what i
was doing he was like cause i kept
getting up and changing outfits kept
changing my office he was like what are
you doing and that's that's like watch
my tick tock
tick tock yeah okay well let's move on
to the top of five performing videos
of the lab crib yeah that's a great one
oh i see me yeah you wish that was you
huh
okay this is something that i feel like
the black community definitely
this is like something that happens in
our in our household
who was the little boy that robbie was
speaking to
um his name is bad kid super marcus
and um he keith had actually broke him
over our manager
and um rob had came up robbie world he
came up with the idea he was like yo
this would be amazing if we do this
he was like all i need you let's ride
around the hoverboard
and he'll take care of the rest so then
it's just like
fantastic i love that and robbie is
hilarious oh yeah
rocky genius ariel so the girls are at
it again back at it again
we're going to do a slippery slide flip
and slide on the boys
[Music]
we need more we need more
we need more we need we need more
first of all i felt my mom come through
me because first thing i heard
somebody's gonna bust their head on that
floor i was like oh my
they're not afraid somebody's gonna slip
and fall and hurt themselves
uh that was the point we kind of worry
because like we were
like as you heard in the video we're
kind of nervous for our manager keith to
walk yeah
yeah we were scared for him to come in
and then barbara
oh yeah there's a barbie here oh my
goodness yeah
yeah so that was crazy by the way
it was trey by the way that you were
sliding i didn't want to get my messed
up so i used trays
what was their reaction after they kind
of figured out what was going on
i think they wanted to get us big we
still waiting
waiting for pranks they haven't really
did anything
y'all are good with these prank words
was that something you already saw on
tick-tock
oh yeah it was tomorrow yeah um i just
came up with it
like because i've always wanted a slip
and slide even though it's winter
like it's kind of cold outside so like
we can't do it outside
so he's like you know what let's do it
indoors on a marble floor
girl i was like i'm getting too old
because my mom definitely just came out
of me
anybody home oh everybody's home alone
the boys had their door open
so
that is such a funny background that has
a very funny i love it
okay so um after all the pranks you know
the boys the boys thought it would be
funny to take our door off the hinges
completely off the hinges and how i'll
do it they like they took the
whole door the whole door off so after
the prank we said hey you guys can you
put our door back
and they tried to put it back but they
didn't put it back right so it wasn't
shutting correctly and they they lost
some screws and they lost the screw they
lost the screws they told us that we had
to go buy our own
right so what we did was took their
screws out there to replace our door
yup okay that makes a lot of sense
because i was like okay so what did she
do
when she found out the doors were open
and then we see her unscrewing
so are they are they missing screws now
yes yes their door is hanging hanging
they i'm having banging eyes
[Applause]
[Music]
it feels really good to just see all
that melanin
and all these black creators like
supporting one another and just in one
space
killing it did you just guys just want
to come out and introduce yourself
so that was actually valid and collab
so that is another um collab house that
our manager also manages
in atlanta another black creator house
and we were actually headed to
the poll to the polls because we did um
yeah so we worked alongside joining the
pearls to
support john ossoff and rafael warnock
so yeah so pretty much we joined along
the whole election the senate election
and we were part of the campaign
yeah we worked hard we are we definitely
worked hard for them votes
what's the energy like with having all
of you guys together how does that feel
genuine yeah i could say that which is a
good feeling yeah
yeah it's good to genuinely be around
black people that want to see other
black people being but also want to work
hard